we're not going to pretend we haven't
thought about what it'd be like to have
superpowers there's a reason that comic
book adaptations dominate the box office
it's a seductive idea imagining how we
might act if we had certain supernatural
abilities that go further than what's
thought to be possible for human beings
abilities that a certain foundation
might consider
anomalous for the record the power we
wish we had was the memetic ability to
make you like subscribe and watch all of
our videos just because you saw the
titles and thumbnails that would be
phenomenal but today we're not here to
talk about us
that's right we're here to talk about
you we have a little tradition here at
scp explained we like to put interesting
scp-related questions to our fans over
in the community posts questions like
what anomalous scp abilities would you
personally want to have and you didn't
disappoint so let's put on our capes and
do our very best to hide from the mobile
task forces hunting us and see which
abilities you selected and why fauna too
said i'd either want the powers of dear
god
scp-2845 or the ability to heal anything
like
scp-500 the ability to heal would be
really neat to be able to do but i
really like the concept of just
summoning pillars and chunks of ice that
never melt i probably wouldn't turn
anyone into a column though a
fascinating combination the deer god is
one of the most powerful reality warpers
that the scp foundation has in
containment luckily its lack of
knowledge about the power of rituals
keep it in a self-imposed trap it's nice
to know that you'd at least use its
immense and terrifying power more
responsibly than the foundation estimate
the deer itself would if ever it escaped
and hey the ability to heal people of
any disease at will would definitely win
you some friends we just hope you're
ready to become very very popular fauna
too anup singha said i just want the
reptile's incredible adaptability and a
ticket to the wanderers library because
let's just agree folks in our world the
only thing that measures greatness is
adaptability leon c meganson inspired by
the works of charles darwin did once say
it is not the strongest of the species
that survives nor the most intelligent
it is the one most adaptable to change
and there's definitely some truth to
that also while it doesn't technically
qualify as having an anomalous ability
having access to the wanderers library
via one of the ways is certainly a great
way to bone up on obscure and arcane
knowledge just remember to keep your
wanderers library card in your wallet
and bring anything you take out back on
time i've heard the late fees from that
library can be
murdered i'm sorry that was a bad joke
enzu said i definitely feel like that if
i had the same abilities as
scp-173 people would tend to look my way
more often quite literally now this
wouldn't be the last time this comes up
so we should probably make the blanket
statement scp explained does not in any
way endorse performing dangerous or
criminal activity that being said if the
power you're referring to is snapping
people's necks while they stop looking
at you then it's technically something
you can do already if you work on your
arm strength and twisting technique
we're not saying you should we're just
saying it's possible something 9 30 said
i'd like a combination of scp-999's
optimism and good vibes and scp-230s
chemical secretion though not as
addictive or fatal after the past couple
of years everyone deserves to feel good
one way or another that is certainly a
noble goal
scp-999 is a beacon of pure happiness
and the aerosolized chemical emitted by
scp-230 also known as the gayest man
alive does undeniably also give
pleasurable sensations to people at the
cost of long-term harm to fuse their
abilities with diminished side effects
would definitely make you a nice person
to be around though much like the next
snapping abilities of scp-173
you can also embody the positivity of
scp-999 in your daily life already and
uplift the people you meet it's
definitely worth thinking about neo
voyagers
said what about the combo that ls used
by combining
scp-268 the invisibility cap and scp-914
the clockworks i feel like it would be
really overpowered a powerful combo
indeed but not without its risks after
all extended use may turn you into an
un-person impossible to focus on alone
and adrift in an isolated and
frightening world but hey you'd be a
pretty amazing petty thief or assassin
at least weeb said i think it'd be
really cool to have an evil tickle
monster where he literally just tickles
you to death so we've got good news and
bad news the bad news is we don't think
it's possible to tickle someone to death
by conventional means would just cause
the victim to eventually faint from the
stress however even in the absence of
anomaly deadly tickling abilities
affixing long blades to your fingers
would probably make your tickle game far
more lethal than ever before that if you
can believe it was the good news i am
gorb said personally i wouldn't really
want to have any sort of mind control or
resistance to weapons because at that
point you'd be more dangerous than most
other anomalies i'd either want to be a
variation of a little mister or have
powers which relate to animals somehow
mind control and resistance to weapons
would indeed make you a more dangerous
anomaly and by extension put a target on
your back for the scp foundation the
last thing you want is to be put in a
medically induced coma to prevent your
brain waves from passively hurting
people a little mister's power would
certainly be a lot nicer unless it was
something like the eternally
fast-tracked life and death of mr life
and mr death that'd probably leave you
begging for the mind control abilities
the real rubric said i would like a
combination of able speed and sword
conjuring with kane's ability to reflect
damage and his immortality it just seems
overpowered and that is why i want it
it's truly the perfect power set for the
kind of person who loves to dish it out
and never expects to take it you may
effectively become the ultimate warrior
but you definitely won't win any friends
in the process like the kid on the
playground with the lava proof shoes
hamza salex said i would choose an
infinitely powerful form of scp-343's
reality bending power we can only
imagine it would play out like a far
more violent and disturbing version of
bruce almighty and personally we can't
wait to see it gwynner said to be
perfectly honest i'd rather have the
ability to not have an ability so i
don't get bundled into the back of a van
in the middle of the night and placed
into a bleach white containment cell to
be prodded and poked by some lab coat
wearing four eyes all offense intended
besides i'd rather be ignorant of the
horror than face the horror you know to
keep my sanity and not suffer like a
delta green agent mole oh come on it's
just for fun and don't act like
containment is such a bad thing either
the foundation has installed a new
selection of especially comfy bunk beds
in their humanoid containment wing as of
late shruggy gaming said i would say
having the reluctant dimension hopper's
powers but with the ability to control
it having it to control time and
location would be awesome too this would
be an excellent power imagine the money
you could save on bus fare or gas for
your car not to mention the fact you
could visit the grinning man in the
dimension of pure darkness whenever you
please what can we say the poor guy gets
lonely sometimes ari workman said i feel
like being able to use 096's ability to
be able to go through anything whenever
i feel like it would be pretty nice
we can't tell if you mean
scp-106 who can phase through solid
objects or if you really do mean scp-096
who can also go through anything while
in his rage state he just leaves a
considerably bigger mess in the process
feel free to clarify down in the
comments anonymous sheed said alright so
i thought of three the extreme
regenerative abilities of 682 the
undyingness of dr bright except perhaps
confined to a more normal artifact and
the powers of the butler from the bell
minus the whole doing what you're told
to do aspect that is a hell of a
combination a super-powered immortal
ultra-adaptive butler who bows to no one
the only hidden downside of taking in
all of these powers is that you'll also
be bound to mr deeds is summoning bell
and considering you're not offering any
services in exchange for your summoning
that bell may wind up gathering dust on
the shelf mcconn cobb said i would love
to see a wholesome combination of
scp-990 dream man and
scp-348 a gift from dad the idea is that
the dream dad would give you a meal a
warning and something positive to end
the dream that would be incredibly
wholesome we just hope that unlike the
actual dream man these dreams wouldn't
cause the people to whom you give them
to die of violent seizures or heart
attacks the day after they've received
them
zeomoenik2580fun said i like the power
of the i'm at the center of everything
that happens to me scp i don't know how
i would utilize this power but it sounds
cool to create stories or to torture
whoever i want
well that's terrifying remind us to
never upset you ish john generia said
scp-5000 suits invisibility and low
detection and i'd also pair that with
053's abilities of forcing death and
attacks the most lethal spy you'd ever
encountered technically you'd be less a
spy and more of a nightmarish spree
killer given that scp-053's
violence-inducing effects are passive
simply being in the presence of people
would cause them to violently murder one
another and never know why fan of action
said i would like abel's powers but with
demonic firearms with infinite ammo
instead of swords i can see why you call
yourself fan of action because that
definitely sounds like the premise of a
lost arnold schwarzenegger movie from
1987.
thunder said a mix of 426 and the
reluctant dimensional hopper one i could
spread the toaster across all reality
yes
spread the toaster
spread me
everywhere
spread me like one spreads peanut butter
or jelly across a fresh slice of toast
our dominion will be total
sahil ahmed said oh boy i would
absolutely love to be able to cook like
scp-5031
an extremely noble pursuit sahihu though
for what it's worth with enough practice
and passion anyone can cook take some
classes watch some tutorials here on
youtube or at least watching ratatouille
would be a good start james clark said i
want to become a reality bender so i can
make my wife fool real
[Music]
you can make her real all you like james
but remember the most important part
just because she's real doesn't mean
she'll want you back okay
okay nova dog 8 24 said i would love to
be 3166
gorfield the thought of brutally
murdering anyone i meet beating them to
death with blunt weapons and feeding
them my flesh has always been a
fascinating idea
yikes now we hate to be that guy nova
dog but once again you technically do
that already
um
[Music]
but don't ollie lampke said i just want
a hat with the ability of the
pan-dimensional vending machine now this
one is truly fascinating does the hat
dispense snacks and drinks is it a
ginormous hat or one of those cheap
plastic beer drinking hats that happens
to dispense interdimensional beverages
perhaps we'll never know cameron hanson
said i would take the coffee machine and
the desire camera's powers and see what
people truly want to drink well that's a
thought-provoking combination the more i
think about it the more its strange
ambiguity disturbs me
mncap1326 said i want to be like scp-001
when day breaks it would be fun to see
masses of flesh slithering around
absorbing more people and animals
all i can say is that you and i have
very different ideas of fun mncat green
koopa said i'll be honest more than
anything in the scp multiverse i want to
release the devourer this isn't even
really a power as much as it is an odd
self-destructive desire to bring about
the apocalypse by proxy wouldn't it be
more fun to have super strength or fly
than release a monster that'll eat all
of humanity yourself included look i'm
just saying it's worth considering sarah
walton said i would want powers like
scp-055
so i could wait why am i here again
that's a good question i think it had
something to do with the um
hold on give me a second
[Music]
nope i lost it polygon said personally i
would want
scp-005 it feels cool to open any door
in existence this would be an excellent
ability with a wide number of
applications but as we learn from green
koopa and his aspirations to free the
devourer not long ago some doors are
just better left closed javon lou clovis
said if dr bright doesn't want his
amulet i can have it i'm fully aware of
the consequences of his immortality but
i won't alter or change them i just want
to outlive everyone and everything is uh
everything okay javon that's certainly a
frightening johann liebert-esque
aspiration but i think outliving all
other life and drifting through the
infinite void of space for an eternity
afterwards isn't nearly as fun as you
might think wizardshark said probably
5094 i'd not only be the greatest
teacher on the planet but i'd also know
practically everything a noble ambition
to be sure the world needs great
teachers and it's not like miss j can
school everyone some brave anomalous
teachers need to take up the mantle
night fury production said i'd borrow
the gender switching stones abilities
the gender switching stone's abilities
would be undeniably useful especially
for transgender people just make sure
you don't use it on the same person too
many times there can be some nasty side
effects bob burt said oh this one's easy
the tomatoes that kill anyone who makes
a terrible joke that would be a
dangerous ability to have in one of
these comment response videos seriously
polandfan said 096 so i can murder
anyone who looks at me personally we'd
recommend therapy to get over this
crippling homicidal shyness though once
again technically this is also something
you could do without anomalous powers we
just strongly recommend that you don't
do it because committing murder is not
cool mr xtreme said i would like to have
the ability of scp-049
not killing with a touch but actually
curing this kovid 19 pandemic i prefer
to have the power of curing every person
affected by the pandemic by a single
touch of my hand the real tragedy is
that your dream is likely shared by the
plague doctor himself he wishes he could
bring life instead of death cures
instead of corruption but such a thing
seems out of the cards for this poor
anomalous dog the christmas [ __ ] said
i'd love to have the abilities of 2786
so i could just stay in a book and not
exist in the real world for a fat minute
honestly i think we've all felt like
that sometimes but hey you don't need
anomalous powers to lose yourself in a
great book for a little while we
thoroughly recommend trying it as long
as it's not an evil book like the
encyclopedia of common diseases or a
chronicle of the devos addison peacock
said i'd love to shape-shift like
scp-953
spontaneously generate pizza like 458 or
the life-saving abilities of the teddy
bear doctor 2295
this is a powerful triple threat we'd
personally watch a prestige television
drama about a person shape-shifting to
live a double life as an anomalous
surgeon and a world-class pizza chef if
any tv executives see this please get in
contact though sadly we will need to
dose you with amnestics afterwards
lindsay j said the incredible brand
integration and longevity powers of
scp-3166
pause for ten thousand years pods until
the sun is a flickering ember and the
face of man is resigned to dust within
the cities
the day when the universe goes cold
this is so frighteningly on point part
of me believes that
scp-3166 somehow actually wrote this
under an alias and if that is the case
we'll need to dispatch a mobile task
force immediately to make sure that jim
davis bill murray and all their many
associates are safe from your lasagna
coded wrath and there you have it folks
the most desirable anomalous abilities
among the scp-explained community for
those curious about the overall
distribution the most commonly requested
abilities were the adaptability of
scp-682
the reality warping powers of scp-343
and heartwarmingly the positivity powers
of scp-999
want to be part of our next video keep
an eye on the community tab and
definitely let us know which power you'd
like to have down in the comments not
because we're working with foundation
field agents who want to root out
possibly anomalous individuals using our
videos to learn more about their inner
workings just because we're curious
honest now go check out
scp-096 look at a picture of shy guy in
space the shy guy questions and theories
and how to actually beat scp-3008 the
infinite ikea for more dreams and
nightmares from the fans of scp
explained